well great nostalgia credit the entire
costume party was ruined I thought we
agreed that you were gonna be Darth
Vader and I was going to be the shadowy
puppet master dark Overlord that
controls you just like in real life
a stout garlic
[Music]
sterile charity okay
yes my program pologize I passed out
after I thought I heard news that there
was another animated Titanic movie but
I'm afraid in your range you have
forgotten that there is another Titanic
and it is your job to review can't I
reviewed it already
[Music]
yes
yes ladies and gentlemen it appears
there's another feature-length ripoff of
James Cameron's Titanic I can't believe
I live in the world where two of these
exist and you think that'd be bad enough
but if you can possibly comprehend this
it is actually worse than the other
version yes there is actually something
out there worse than this I know it's
hard to believe but this actually is
more terrible than the rapping dog
so what abomination of hell could
possibly make it into the human world
let's find out so strangely enough this
version also focuses on talking mice
that snuck aboard the Titanic somebody
actually found it necessary to rip off
the rip-off moving on it turns out that
an old sailor mouse is telling his
grandkids what really happened the day
the Titanic sunk tragic ending to the
maiden voyage of the Titanic hundred
missing a lot of people died huh the
truth of the matter is that those
missing persons were never really
missing it's a long and complicated
story really so that's how you're
starting this movie out by saying the
hundreds of people that died on the
Titanic didn't really die on the Titanic
it's all misunderstanding one of these
days I'll tell you the whole story yeah
bring it in
[Music]
oh right all right you misters you
talked me into it I'll tell you the
whole story yes please do
my curiosity for this story that
involves everyone surviving one of the
biggest disasters in the world it's
really quite fucking Pete again so of
cars we go into a flashback that shows
grandpa has a much younger Mouse who was
a sailor on the Titanic but hey if
having a flashback isn't similar enough
to that other film what do you say we
have an exact shot replicas for the
reveal of our leading lady this is rose
I mean Rose I mean Rose I mean Elizabeth
she's excited to be on Titanic except
for one tiny little detail she has to
marry a man that she doesn't love yeah
so fucking familiar thought it'd be fair
even though Billy's name was basically a
cartoony bad guy they at least tried to
make him look like a civilized gentleman
here they just left on an iPad Geneva
mustache and anything else that would
make him look like a James Bond villain
that or the ball is from Harvey Birdman
I'd rather dive and marry that I'm
horrifying
disgusting oldest don't be impertinent
you have a position to keep up your
stepmother and I simply want what's best
and if we say that the best for you is
the worst for you then it's the best for
you but at least the stuff with the cute
little talking mice will be fun
right wrong all these mice do throughout
most of the movies talk about ship
protocol yeah ship protocol isn't that
exciting whatever oh cool if you please
aye aye sir mr. and mrs. Angus Wallace
Bruce Mac Mouse mr. and mrs. pouring
Liam a rat and two children Kwan and a
veto right on with offspring jean-luc
and Francois ratatouille and the mouse
Eddie family from Sicily
featuring parmigiano pecorino gorgonzola
problem fontina Cavallo ricotta lots
Heinrich and fro Greta from Mouse case'
with agile swarm oh and Becky boys you
and the Silva Pereira pencil family from
Recife with two children Ronnie and
Estrela thanks lonely now with the
morning procedures so we go what that
rope is daddy - right there but you have
to learn sailor talk Oh No landlubbers
caught our rope the worst it's an all
zap hey remember when we used to just
sneak aboard and eat shit till we go
back to those days so Elizabeth comes
across a group of gypsies live by tuxedo
mask here who tells his dog to try and
get Elizabeth's attention good boy
what a lovely thought Kota you have hair
that's better he doesn't
you idiot I told you to get her necklace
what kind of stupid mutt are you oh well
you suddenly got creepy I'm very sorry
sir but the animal must be kept on a
leash my good man you happen to be
addressing Don Juan Tenorio dar Takens
honestly on who goes around six names
Prince of Andalusia but does not travel
with animals you imbecile oh and I have
to M Prince - there - yeah fuck it I'll
call him Joe now step aside and let us
board they establish the dog has no
owner the dog is still allowed on anyway
oh wait after he pees on it first oh oh
it's not like I can just go up there and
get you for that I don't just throw my
hat - that'll teach you don't let me
down the dog I guess there's nothing
else it really would have done no now I
hate my hat I hate my hat so much my
motivations are so confusing
[Music]
so after leaving the town of genetic
clones I'm not kidding look look we see
our villain named mal Travers talk about
his plans as a winner
there's no reason whatsoever why the
Duke shouldn't grant me exclusive
worldwide whaling rights not to mention
the hand of his dying daughter by
marrying her you'll get your mix on all
of this money there's nothing in the
world that counts besides money and
power everything else is simply there to
be used to achieve those objectives I
think we just saw the meeting for how
this movie got green-lighted so we get
one of those phoned in CGI shots of the
ship as the captain discusses what he's
gonna do for the evening there's only
one thing worse than a party and that's
a guy like mr. Craig haven't called for
any problem whatsoever and if there
aren't any make one up oh you mean like
iceberg right ahead
oh good our mousey friends got away from
the rest of the team I guess that means
there's not gonna be any more ship
rotellini you know too lately that key
on construction and materials so for the
first two days be careful how you move
up oh yeah whatever scene there's no
Captain America
but eventually they do get away from the
group and they see what's going on in
the first-class quarters she's beautiful
as a picture and as fiery as the
feijoada Connie oh come here in my
dreams throughout the world I hate to be
a spoilsport but I would like to go to
your attention about the chaise a woman
and you're a mouse this beautiful oh
there is one thing I'm not and that's
the reason what though there is one
thing I'm not and that's the reason do
we really just take a situation with two
mice a young woman and somehow come out
with racism how do you do that first of
all it's not racism as much as species
Gizem second why is he fantasizing about
a human female don't we have enough
weird fetishes already with that crazy
pull up smelling fucktard
let's give the oddness to a minimum oh
god I spoke too soon just when you
thought things couldn't get any weirder
things couldn't possibly get more fucked
up take a gander at this thanks to a
magic moonbeams that caught your tears
as they fell into the water we added a
little bit magic of our own and while
the spell was cast father okay am I
dreaming this I really must be dreaming
this I really can't comprehend this oh
yeah I mean okay we now have magic
dolphins who apparently can fly because
well how the hell else are they staying
up there so long who can suddenly talk
to her because her Rainbow Brite tears
cause some Moonbeam bullshit and now
everything's coming up doctor do but
sure why not okay you can talk to
dolphins now arguably one of the most
intelligent creatures on the entire
planet so what exactly you're gonna say
to them if I could turn into a dolphin
like you that would make me happy
that's great young lady that's great you
wish you were a doll fine okay for the
sake of argument let's say that you
stayed in the theatre after you saw this
scene what exactly are they gonna do
with this revelation we're engaged in a
disk
athol to save the lives of our friends
the whale come out Travis ships are
hunting the poor thing is near to
extinguish it I'm sorry which story are
we watching the love story the ship the
mice the whales what is the focus you
can't just throw this incredibly bizarre
bullshit at us and just expect us to go
along with it I mean it's like saying
hey the Titanic wasn't destroyed by an
iceberg it was a evil gang of underwater
sharks we're in cahoots with the evil
Whaler hey me the boys they're ready to
go into action anytime you say guy ice I
have a message from the boss Daniel
Aiden don't stray too far from the ship
fella we're ready to destroy anything
any time I'm sorry I need to try
something I'm sorry I can't get through
this in one sitting if you'll excuse me
I'm gonna take the occasional break to
look at myself in the mirror and cry
[Music]
how do we go so why can the bad guys
communicate with the criminal underwater
shark tank we don't know it's never
explained
maybe he got some of that Moonbeam
bullshit from a crack dealer or
something but as of now he doesn't want
them to destroy the ship just yet
he just wants them to stay close but
luckily seems that magic also seems to
work with mice as Elizabeth can suddenly
understand them now - you ought to face
the issue squarely and tell your father
ever I'd what you think he's God I'm
like of course I'm going to fight no I
know you two are on my side we could
foil override and help those poor widow
food yes now that they're on your side
I'm sure you'll have a great case to go
up against your father father I know you
want me to marry that man but I've been
talking with the dolphins and mice and
they agree that it's not the right thing
to do but Elizabeth does go to set the
record straight and it turns out her
father takes it unrealistically well I
have absolutely no intention of marrying
ever art I'm sorry - it fit your plans
but plans did you say one another they
plan their goal is to see you as happy
as possible but I would never dream of
forcing you to do something you don't
want it was the beginning of the movie
in which case I said you have no choice
seriously what did she do different she
made the same argument she did before in
fact it's actually less angry are you
honestly telling me that this I have
absolutely no intention of marrying ever
art it's much more stronger than this
I'd rather dive and marry that a
horrifying disgusting Oh PMS talkie
you'll get over it I have absolutely no
intention of marrying everyone
whoa whoa cool down bitch call that Oh
all right we'll figure this out man
Jesus but meanwhile down this hallway or
maybe it's this hallway no because it's
this hallway
the bad guy is looking to make sure his
evil wedding schemes go according to
plan but luckily the mites kick him with
a soccer ball and send him home
isley flying down the ship seems kind of
pointless seeing how we already know
that Elizabeth isn't going to marry him
but he'll we need something to top the
dog pissing scene don't we meanwhile
apparently Jo is still in this movie as
we see he spends most of his time oh god
get over it god I miss Elizabeth almost
as much as I miss Vanessa but it turns
out the animals lead them together and
they finally discover each other and of
course they decide to date but unlike
the other animated Titanic movie where
they shared only three lines of dialogue
and decide they love each other here
they only share one line of dialogue
yeah one fucking line of dialogue and
they know it's meant to be I guess you
consider sniffing the glove first base
but the whaler and evil stepmother it
turns out are in cahoots with each other
and they want to stop them from hooking
up I've been clear enough
if mr. Maltravers is so important to you
then you marry him
actually that's a great idea if she's so
evil why doesn't she just leave
Elizabeth's father and go with the
whaler guy doesn't that make more sense
whatever it seems that boat has sailed
her saying so I guess it's better just
to cut their losses and move on to the
next logical step hold the father up at
gunpoint force him to sign the whaling
concession and tie him up so he won't
escape tell me when do the same thing so
he sends the message to the whalers that
they're allowed to hunt wherever they
please but luckily the mice cut the
wires before the message can get out I'm
sure that will backfire in any way but
wait what the father tied up someone's
liable to come across it so again what's
the logical thing to do the ship has to
sing tonight but remember not a second
before midnight or else all your work
will have been for nothing
considering Valley midnight that's right
it's the evil gang of sharks that sank
the Titanic because of a needless Li
complex wailing school aren't you glad
we're simplifying the emotions of a
horrendous tragedy to an insulting Li
basic battle of good versus evil
after we've arranged for the ice bike to
appear in front of it we'll hold the
rudder adoptees keep it on cause why do
these Titanic movies need a bad guy
isn't the iceberg sort of a designated
villain well let's just call it a bet a
couple of my boys think they can even
high-spade farther than tentacles can
that sounds like great fun so the shirts
trick a giant octopus named tentacles
into an iceberg throwing contest uh-huh
there's a giant octopus with a dog's
face in this movie and they're only
waiting till the last third to show it
way to subtly wheel us into that
suspension of disbelief the shark said
I'm throwing you through an iceberg and
shipboard people I don't know how many
of them will be able to save it's not
like he can just grab the iceberg and
push it out of the way away yes he can
why don't you just grab the iceberg and
push it out of the way so the wheeler
and stepmother is deep on the boat and
not to give anything away but the
iceberg hits the ship Hey considering
how much else they change in this movie
as a prize they kept that if true of us
in DotA as I said maybe there's a we
spent two hours talking about ship front
at all and you didn't even file it for
backs on y'all so they try to fix the
wires with the help of another mouse
named cannon bear get it it's a cheese
but the wires won't stretch far enough
so there's only one thing to do
[Music]
yes this will be an incredibly funny
scene if it didn't end up killing him no
seriously it ends up Killian look what a
hero
okay there's a lot of moments in a
titanic movie where you're supposed to
have a serious debt see you picked one
oh and unlike that downer Cameron movie
where there weren't enough lifeboats
this film sets the record straight see
this room for everybody what did you
think those idiots at the History
Channel know what they were talking
about no no it's the version with the
giant talking octopus that has it right
so Elizabeth and Joe find the father and
set him free allow him to get on the
lifeboat why doesn't the daughter go to
or for that matter why not the boyfriend
did you just hear the guy before
everyone - hop aboard it doesn't matter
if you have testicles in this movie you
can still make it out
but don't worry tentacles is there to
put the ship back together that's right
he's putting the ship back together and
just in case there's any confusion for
this being mistaken for a tragic act of
nature the truth is it's all my fault
no it's not your fault this all happened
because of an evil greedy human being
you heard her right there fault it was
all because of an evil human being the
realities of life don't play here hey
the next time a family member dies just
tell your kid a whaler did it it's all
cool I mean hey as long as you can
fucking blame something while you're
pondering why an octopus has to hold his
breath to go underwater it turns out
that dolphins have good news
[Music]
there'd be whales here so the whales
seem to save everybody on the ship even
the captain yeah because we all know he
made it out okay
but unfortunately tentacles can't hold
on anymore and goes down with the ship
[Music]
[Laughter]
but we have a wedding to cut - that's
right
Elizabeth and Joe finally got married as
dick Tramp a mouse and that blonde who
he only shared one line with seriously
do these guys ever start a dialogue when
suddenly their attention is drawn to the
river that's right tentacles is alive
and look even camembert with no
explanation whatsoever somehow made it
out okay I thought you were dead that's
right even though there were no whales
or people in that shot you just saw
apparently everybody made it out alive
thank god this isn't the least bit
insulting to the hundreds of people who
tragically lost their lives or else this
could possibly be the worst thing we
ever produced as a species tentacles you
are a true hero and the many people who
couldn't find space in the lifeboats you
saved their lives to tell us how you
accomplished such an amazing feat it was
the whales who did it really wailing
shit in this movie well if you want to
make a movie about whales that's fine
more power to you
but leave the deaths of hundreds of
innocent people out of it if you don't
mind I mean even Fergal he just stuck to
the rain forest they didn't try to work
in the Hindenburg disaster or anything
so this Ronnie Ronnie Stella's brother
so flashback to present day if the kids
realize grandpa has clearly gone off his
meds and made this entire story up that
means nobody's on the way to meal on her
[Music]
unfortunately no children have always
been another Everard Maltravers name has
been changed but their evil lives on the
whales are still ample shut up I hope we
nuke those fucker so we don't get any
more movies like this you guys enough is
enough
your grandfather loves to tell stories
but like all sailors you should be taken
too soon understatement of the fucking
millennia
[Music]
so just to recap everybody nobody died
on the Titanic animals can talk with
moon magic sharks form underwater gangs
whales are Jesus and the reveal the
giant talking octopus in New York I've
absolutely no media attention whatsoever
so to sum up nah I need a minute
[Music]
look can you see why this is worse than
the other one I mean the animation is
better but this goes from stupid to
disgustingly insulting just the idea
that people took this tragedy and turn
it into such a lame ploy to save the
whales is mind boggling the Titanic
story has nothing to do with whale so
why'd you make that connection it's
insulting to history it's insulting to
children's intelligence and it
straight-up insulting to the people who
died honestly it's sort of hard to watch
it's so horrendous I mean it honestly
makes this film look more realistic the
film with the rapping dog is actually
closer to the real story of the Titanic
that is a new low for a kids movie to
sink it's beyond shit and my guess is
it'll take days before you stop feeling
unclean from it my only hope is that
people will finally learn their lesson
and stop making animated spin-offs off
this shit
[Music]
well there's one thing I'm not and
that's a reason